President Trump asked Congress for an
almost five billion dollar loan to help
Puerto Rico in the wake of Hurricane
Maria only 16% of the US territory has
electricity
FEMA awarded nearly 55 million dollars
yesterday to the Puerto Rico electric
and Power Authority the death toll has
risen to 45 david beg no is in the Ocean
Park neighborhood of San Juan David good
morning Nora good morning a potential
health crisis is one thing that gives
the governor of Puerto Rico pause and
contaminated water is key to that look
at the water where we are in San Juan
it's purple let me show you this the
water right here has been here for four
weeks before Maria this was here since
her and it's backed up by the trash city
workers were told they're overwhelmed
don't have the time to collect all the
trash in the city so it's left up to
people to come and sweep the streets in
front of their home we've literally seen
people reaching into drains to pull out
trash so that the water can recede two
people died from symptoms of
leptospirosis tests are pending right
now but officials believe that was the
cause of death five other people who
have symptoms of the bacterial infection
are being treated with antibiotic look
clean water is key and for whatever
reason nobody seems to be able to figure
out how to get enough clean water to
everyone on this island who needs it's
been three weeks since Hurricane Maria
devastated Puerto Rico and from the air
it looks like the storm hit yesterday
blue tarps cover homes where roofs were
damaged or ripped off we were with the
governor Ricardo Rosa yo as he flew over
some of the hardest hit areas by
helicopter
picketed
[Music]
on the southern part of the island in
Ponce a grocery stores are running low
on food and water nearby at a
distribution center in and Yasko
families are given one box of food it's
supposed to last them a day or two so
you guys have been helping each other
ISA Belle Morales got a box for four
family members she says they have very
little food but even less water we just
need a lot of water yeah we don't find
it it's really hard to find it not far
from here in the Atalaya neighborhood of
an Inc all families are bathing in
rainwater we use it because we don't
have any other option lissandra
Candelaria told us three weeks later
she's still sifting through what's left
of her home
pictures are a painful reminder of life
before the hurricane I wish this was all
the dreams she says and I could go back
to when my house was still standing for
her 11 year old son Hetty el it's hard
to understand I wish my home was fixed
he says so I can continue to live in the
place where I grew up we talked to a
police officer in Ponce a on the
southern part of the island who said on
a recent shift thirty-eight police
officers had only 19 bottles of water
they all got about a half bottle each
Noir David beg no continuing your
incredible reporting there in Puerto
Rico thank you so much we appreciate it